the Joe Rogan experience did I uh did I
show you that that lion that we were
extracting DNA from and Zimbabwe did I
tell you about this I don't think so
dude this was pretty nuts so in late
last year I was tracking this giant lion
that this friend of mine had told me
that he'd seen in this in Limpopo Valley
of Zimbabwe like just north of the south
african border and we surmised that
there was a potential that this animal
because it was so big it had such unique
behavior in the fact that it was hunting
Buffalo and even even juvenile elephants
might have remnant Cape lion DNA in it
because the Cape lion was his extinct
subspecies of African lion it was bigger
than your regular lion and they would
follow the elephant migrations north and
then back south but generally they hung
out in South Africa anyway long story
short we wanted to test the DNA of this
lion to see if it had any Cape lined DNA
in it and it was this one individual
animal so we tracked it for over a week
hung bait every night you know did the
callers did everything that you do to
get get a lion in and then finally this
massive black mane lion came in and I
darted it from about 30 feet away from a
block yeah 30 feet but wait it gets
worse I was in a blind so I felt kind of
safe right but when I hit it I had dosed
for and it wasn't even me we had a vet
with us he had dosed for a regular sized
African lion so the animal takes off
running as we hit in the head in the
back recorders we check you know trot
after it on foot looking for it and we
get up to it we're like oh he's down
okay time to do our work up and I start
walking up to it to check it as you do
when you've tracked an animal I get Joe
from me to that to that television the
big one right there and it pops up he's
like hello it's not all the way asleep
and I just dropped to the ground and
just go dude just go limp right cuz I'm
like crap this is he's gonna come and
kill me and fortunately he was drugged
up enough even though he wasn't asleep
to just kind of like not know where I
was and like didn't really charge but
growled and came forward a step or two
and then kind of turned turned off and
laid back down again there we got
another track into him and he went to
sleep but it was really scary how big
was he I think there's a did you wants
to show them the picture on my on my
page huge I mean I don't know lion
weights or points or you know any of the
hunting stats but but unusually large oh
yeah biggest one I've ever seen and I
grew up there
huge did you get the DNA and did they
run the test we did and there was a 14%
discrepancy between it and regular South
African lion DNA so there's something
off so there's something off so we
couldn't quite figure out what it was we
drew blood we took hair clippings and
the latest is you know it's not again
I'm not a geneticist but the latest is
that sample has been sent down to South
Africa to run against Cape Line DNA to
try and figure out what the discrepancy
is but yeah there was a discrepancy so
there is something unique and unusual
definitely something unique and unusual
you see if I can find it quickly it's a
big big animal and I've got on my phone
otherwise I know this is boring for no
you worry about it it's just this
massive lion and to have him charge me
on foot it was pretty terrifying so
you're talking about something that's
twice the size of a normal one I would
say like yeah yeah 25 to 50% larger I
mean the paws were just it's just yeah
I'll show you on my phone I can send it
to you guys but it's just huge huge okay
a black mane unbelievable animal so
that's when he's tranked yeah so that's
it see the durian is back oh that's just
a picture of a picture but that's this
time he pops up when we go to China my
god dude he's so big huge huge and
there's some pictures you'll see in a
second of him on the ground when we're
doing the workup is that him right there
yeah putting a collar on him jack I mean
just a massive massive animal do you
guys know what the size of a sack yeah
he's hung Jesus guys know how old he is
um we didn't actually look into that I'm
not sure I'd be fascinated by that yeah
so this was crazy but keep us informed
on yet that discrepancy turns out to be
yeah it's fascinating you know that work
takes a long time and it travels around
but we've got the sample which was the
main objective so they used to be a
North American lion that was even larger
than the African lion significantly yeah
yeah significantly crazy yeah and that
was not that long ago right like when
the last fifteen thousand years ago or
something like that I believe it was
definitely coexisted with human beings
[ __ ] yeah we had Lions yep huge ones
yeah and big Plains game and ever
[Applause]